[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 loisirs chaque jeudi
l'essentiel des informations pour passer
un bon week-end dans les yvelines et
tout de suite le sommaire il n'y a pas
d'âge pour jouer à saint quentin en
yvelines on l'a bien compris et du 10 au
23 novembre de nombreux événements
autour des jeux sont organisés s quel
gamer de repartir ou encore l'exposition
sculpture peinture ou encore des 150
artistes français investissent le carré
à la farine jusqu'au 17 novembre pour le
254e salon de versailles et l'agenda
complet de vos sorties au programme du
cinéma du sport et une exposition
mesdames ce premier rendez vous et pour
vous ce samedi 9 novembre le club mouche
de plaisir nous propose une initiation à
la pêche à la mouche dès 8h30 les
membres du club vous apprendront toutes
les ficelles de la discipline de la
conception d'une mouche au choix du
matériel
vous pourrez ensuite vous exercer sur le
plan d'eau du château de la ville dans
lequel des truites auront été introduite
pour vous inscrire direction le site
internet qui s'affiche à l'écran et la
présidente du club vous présente la
discipline en quelques mots la pêche à
la mouche consiste à attraper le poisson
mais de le relâcher tout de suite et en
plus on pêche avec des hameçons parce
que i'm so i lya pour attraper du
poisson qui ne font pas mal parce qu'il
n'ya plus d'art dit ion n'ya pas le
petit crochet qui est à l'intérieur du
de l'hameçon pour cela il n'y a pas d'
appât naturel donc on ne met pas les
mains dans le pot 2 sticks eau ni à les
sortir des verts des vers de terre
donc on est sur une page qui est propre
les vacances de la toussaint sont
terminées mais pas les moments pour
jouer en famille ou entre amis du 10 au
23 novembre ce sont donc les lui 10 days
un rendez vous concocté par les
passionnés de jeux pour les passionnés
de jeux marie-pierre caruhel bon joker à
rueil bonjour mention alors vous êtes
l'une des organisatrices de ce
rendez-vous mais déjà pourquoi mettre
les jeux à l'honneur
alors pourquoi mettre les jeux à
l'honneur à saint quentin c'est que en
fait en médiathèque depuis plusieurs
années nous avons constitué des
collections de jeux de société jeux
vidéo et nous proposons régulièrement
maintenant des ateliers pour tous
publics essentiellement jeunesse mais
ces événements annuels sont l'occasion
par contre de réunir tous les publics
j'arrête bien au delà de 7 à 77 ans
vraiment là et le jeu aujourd'hui une
pratique culturelle très répandu et très
apprécié
c'est à dire que ce n'est pas que pour
les gamers absolument pas non la lavande
nous nous intéressons vraiment à tout
public alors il ya différents temps
forts lors de celui du décès le premier
c'est le 10 novembre
c'est le premier justement ce à la
commanderie on va devoir faire preuve de
déduction et de logique qu'il y aura des
intrigues est aussi un espace jeux de la
liberté donc on nous proposons et la csé
en sont déjà complètes voilà donc je
vous en parle mais avec j'espère ne pas
générer trop de frustration donc nous
proposons deux séances de murder
des séances des skins game qui sont
toutes complètes mais nous avons aussi
un espace jeux de société l'occasion de
de jouer en famille nous serons là
présent avec l'association entre cas de
jeu qui est qu on retrouvera aussi sur
un autre événement de delhi 10 days
puisque nous allons après le week-end
suivant 16 et 17 novembre
nous vous proposons un grand festival de
jeu je tends to say étage pour tout
public
c'est la cinquième édition du festi jeu
de villepreux sur ces deux jours avec un
espace jeux de société jeux vidéo
espaces ludiques pour les plus petits
voilà cinquième édition et on l'a c'est
un événement qui réunit beaucoup
beaucoup de public je vous avais parlé
de ville presque en fait
l'élu dit weis bouge il ya pas que le
kop commanderie tout le monde est sur le
pont tout les toutes les villes va tout
sur toutes les communes de saint quentin
il ya il ya des événements jeu sur cette
quinzaine
et il ya aussi des animations
différentes en fonction des âges
notamment c'est pas comme ceux de 7 à 67
ans ça va plus bas même plus bas bien
sûr bien sûr dans toutes les
médiathèques nous avons une attention
particulière aux plus jeunes publics au
tout public pour ce qui est de la
lecture de l'initiation livres mais
aussi au jeu et donc à l'éducation à
l'éveil culturel du tout petits qui est
fondamental c'est qu'on peut jouer via
des jeux de société pour les tout-petits
aux jeux de manipulation il ya des jeux
d'image bien sûr le jeu est adapté à
tout âge à partir du moment où on peut
manipuler et toutes ces animations vont
prendre fin le 23 novembre mais ont fait
durer le plaisir jusqu'à minus que c'est
la nuit du jeu l'ani du jeu tout à fait
donc au muy med
dans tous les espaces du mu mène donc il
réunit musée et médiathèque avec la
essentiellement l'invitation
d'associations locales de jeu il y en a
de nombreuses donc on retrouvera entre
quatre jeux mais bien d'autres
associations locales
la ludothèque de montigny également et
donc jeux vidéo jeux de société il y en
aura pour tous les goûts des grands jeux
tableau si nous avons une collection de
grands jeux en bois sur le réseau que
nous sortons à différentes occasions
donc il y en a vraiment pour tous tes
coups et ça pourrait peut-être donner
des idées pour la liste au père noël
après so lu ment notamment sur festival
du jeu vous pourrez trouver des
boutiques
de vente de jeux que vous pourrez tester
et acheter si le coeur vous en dit vous
demander au père noël
merci marie pierre caruhel alors les où
l'élu d'idex débute ce dimanche 10
novembre la programmation est à
retrouver sur le site internet kiosque
pense qu'ils point fr les années folles
s'empare du théâtre montansier à
versailles y est c'est la dernière
création de la compagnie les brigands et
qui raconte l'histoire de maxime le fils
d'un indice industriel milliardaire qui
cherchent à échapper à un mariage imposé
par son père une opérette créée en 1928
par maurice yvain sur scène neuf
chanteurs et trois musiciens
c'est aussi une jolie chronique sociale
des années 20 on croise le majordome qui
veut être député communiste du 16e
arrondissement le coiffeur qui va
devenir une star de music hall où tout
se mélange un petit peu la politique qui
dans les années 20 et années 30 avait
beaucoup de saveur avec la montée de la
gauche la droite conservatrice etc
et puis et puis les fortunes et les
infortunes qui à l'époque pouvait aller
très vite
[Musique]
la saison d'à pas de géant débute ce
week-end l'association guyancourt 3
propose ce samedi 9 novembre son
traditionnel match inter générationnelle
de l'improvisation qui composent
l'équipe adulte d improbables et les
cadets des imprononçable début de la
rencontre à 20h30
c'est le moment du rendez vous
hebdomadaire des cinémas cette semaine
gaël pineau vous invite au grenier à sel
de trappes pour les 20 ans du mois
documentaire
[Musique]
ça fait longtemps que le mois du
documentaire existe c'est une
manifestation nationale qui met en avant
les films de documentaires
nous attendons un petit peu
cet événement sur le mois de novembre
pour mettre en valeur les films
documentaires donc là on a pas mal de
film en stock au grenier à sel vous
découvrirez pour les soldats tombés qui
est un documentaire réalisé par peter
jackson donc le réalisateur du seigneur
des anneaux du public
il a mis en couleur il à son arrivée
des images d'archivés de 14 18 de
l'armée anglaise c'est phénoménal
à découvrir sur grand écran je vous
propose aussi le documentaire pour sabah
nous sommes donc à alep en syrie et ça
va être un été qui vient de naître et sa
maman
vie le siège au jour le jour et film
tout ce qui se passe avec son bébé et à
l'hôpital où elle travaille découvrez
donc pour sabah et pour les soldats
tombés cette semaine au cinéma le
grenier à sel puis de 50 artistes réunis
au carré à la farine la société
versaillaise des artistes d'île de
france organise jusqu'au 17 novembre son
154e salon de versailles de la peinture
à la sculpture les artistes franciliens
sont rassemblés autour de deux invités
d'honneur techniques différentes mais un
point commun tous les artistes présentés
sont franciliens un choix de la société
versaillaise des artistes d'île de
france pour son 154e salon on a mélangé
chaque année on a on a des gens qui ne
sont pas professionnels et d'autres qui
sont professionnels donc on a fait un
choix en disant que ce qui n'était pas
professionnelle pouvait exposer une
oeuvre et les autres jusqu'à 3 une
quinzaine d'artistes yvelinois a été
sélectionnés dont la sculptrice
guyancourt toiser duc et un mari ponsard
d'entre eux basés au vésinet je
travaille sur une année sur un thème qui
m'est venue en revenant de voyage
alors ça c'était en venant d'afrique
j'ai changé les couleurs j'ai changé
tant de choses j'en ai fait un autre
avant qui est beaucoup plus figurative
disons et puis petit à petit le travail
évolue et devient
plus abstrait sculptures peintures
gravures autour de deux artistes invités
elizabeth hoodless originaire de
versailles travaille le métal de
récupération ses proches du modelage
pour moi voilà je trouve c'est un
matériau
qui est qui et qui est noble alors je
travaille toujours avec du métal de
récupération
j'aime le côté
les matériaux qui a déjà vécu plus de 60
oeuvres sont rassemblés au coeur du
carré à la farine de versailles
à découvrir jusqu'au 17 novembre il est
l'auteur d'une saga aux 150 millions
d'exemplaires vendus le britannique jrr
tolkien a avec ses ouvrages créer des
mondes des cartes et même des landes une
exposition lui est consacrée à la
bibliothèque nationale de france
un sujet en terre du milieu de nos
confrères de via grand paris
plongez au coeur de l'univers de tolkien
à la bnf révolutionnaire du genre
fantastique
l'auteur britannique aurait inspiré plus
d'une génération avec son oeuvre
le seigneur des anneaux voyage en terre
du milieu est une exposition xxl qui
revient en profondeur sur la trilogie
littéraire la plus célèbres du 20e
siècle
elle présente des pièces uniques de
tolkien montrant tour le travail de
recherche et de précision qu'il a fait
pendant plus de 12 ans il le dit dans
une de ces correspondances que c'est
important de commencer par la carte pour
être sûr de la cohérence ensuite de leur
il crée vraiment un monde en fait dans
son entièreté c'est à dire qu'il invente
la création de ce monde la mythologie de
ce monde comme en ce monde a été créé et
est donc toujours un souci de grande
cohérence à la fois par les cartes
également par les langues qu'il crée
pour ces peuples
il a vraiment pensé à quelle distance
pourrait parcourir un hobbit par exemple
par rapport à un cavalier du rohan et
s'ils doivent se retrouver à tel endroit
combien de temps ça va prendre est
également une chronologie sur où et est
les différents protagonistes de
l'histoire qu'est ce qu'il faisait à
telle date
voyage en terre du milieu immerge
pleinement les visiteurs dont le monde
inventé par tolkien
chaque partie de l'exposition s'attarde
sur une région de la terre du milieu
le rendez vous laisse cependant
l'opportunité à chaque personne de
s'imaginer comme il l'entend cet univers
il n'y a d'ailleurs aucune allusion au
film de peter jackson
ce qu'on voulait dans cette exposition
c'était ne pas plaquer un imaginaire on
sait qu'il ya des visiteurs qui vont
venir avec une certaine idée qui se
seront fait indépendamment des
représentations cinématographiques et
nous ce qu'on voudrait ce qu'on aimerait
c'est que les visiteurs découvrent
l'oeuvre de tolkien pour elles mêmes qui
reviennent aux écrits de tolkien et puis
à tous ces dessins qu'on connaît moins
qu'on connaît pas forcément qui sont
autant de représentations aussi de cette
oeuvre qui pour le coup sont au plus
près de l'auteur puisqu'elles sont de sa
main venez découvrir l'oeuvre incroyable
de tolkien à la bnf jusqu'au 7 février
c'est la fin du set eu tout loisir merci
de nous avoir suivi on sur votre jeudi
prochain pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je